now good evening and thank you for
joining us tonight at 11 o'clock i'm
sasha loftis two people are dead tonight
in what police believe to be a murder
suicide this happened on east fremont
street downtown at the fremont nine
apartments madison kimbrough joins us
live after speaking with officers and
neighbors in the area so madison what
are police saying
police believe this incident happened
days ago a man and woman's body were
found here this afternoon at this
apartment complex here at fremont nine
i'm out here this evening to brief you
on what appears to be a murder-suicide
investigation near the intersection of
ninth in fremont this happened around 2
30 saturday afternoon a white man in his
40's and a white woman in her 50's were
both found dead inside one of the
apartments at fremont 9. the initial
call that came in
was from a
neighbor who had went and checked on the
occupants that neighbor was able to
obtain a key they went inside and found
both the male and the female that same
neighbor is the person who heard them
arguing on tuesday it's unclear if the
two people were in a relationship but
they did live together in the apartment
residents of this downtown complex
saying the whole scenario is not
something they would have ever expected
to happen here shocked just shocked
riding around came home saw like 11 cop
cars did not know what was happening we
have a lot of security actually in the
building at the same time it's kind of
nerve-racking the preliminary
investigation suggests the two had died
from gunshot wounds and police confirm
that the incident did not happen
saturday as it's likely the murder
suicide took place two days ago i talked
to a lot of the people in the building i
used a lot of the amenities and i'm at
the pool in the clubhouse a lot i never
saw anything that made me feel like that
was something that was happening